political stakes are high as president
Trump in the GOP now tried to tackle tax
reform after failing to repeal Obamacare
will they succeed the president made his
way to Indianapolis this afternoon to
roll out a sweeping plan to overhaul the
tax code we're going to cut taxes for
the middle class make the tax code
simpler and more fair for everyday
Americans and we are going to bring back
the jobs and wealth that have left our
country and most people thought left our
country for good we want tax reform that
is pro-growth pro-jobs pro worker
pro-family and yes tax reform that is
pro-american the president's farm would
slash the corporate tax rate to 20% from
35% and lower the top individual tax
rate from thirty nine point six percent
to thirty five here's more from mr.
Trump a short while ago it's time for
Washington to learn from the wisdom of
Indiana we need Washington to promote
American jobs instead of obstructing
them that is what I've been working to
achieve every day since I took office
that is what I talked about on the
campaign trail already we're seeing the
results of an economic policy that
finally puts America first
okay so Dana now the lot of people in
have an opinion about this because there
are people are very strong supporters of
the president of his campaign and the
policies that he was planning and one of
the big things was tax reform they
definitely need to be able to achieve
something because especially coming on
the heels of yet another failed attempt
with health care how did you feel the
President did today in terms of his
messaging and what about the content
well I think the rollout has been fairly
good I think that he had to give this
speech on the teleprompter but I hope
that he doesn't do a ton of them on them
because I think because health tax
reform hasn't been done really well in
30 years and I think his ability to sell
it in plain spoken words in the way that
he does is actually probably one of the
best things he has going for them
I think that the text of the plan and
then end of the speech if you read it on
paper is a little bit in the weeds but
you can get the base basically get the
gist they are going to have obstacles
already the left is painting this as tax
cuts for the rich and this is only going
to benefit the wealthy that is not true
but it is just it's hard to argue it on
the other side I think that he started
to do that today and I think based on
what I've heard that the White House has
a pretty good plan to keep their
coalition together in order to try to
advance this but if you really do think
the rich are going to end up paying more
so if you are in the tax code or in the
zip code where you really wanted Hillary
Clinton to win like you should be glad
because you thought the rich should pay
more and under this plan they are going
to end up paying more okay so Greg do
you think they're gonna get that that
they get the messaging and actually
understand the you know the contents of
this tax reform to say or just be
obstruction and say we don't like it no
matter what it is even if it tax the
rich because President Trump is putting
it forward I just item no matter how
whenever they say they're simplifying
something it's never truly simplified
simplified they still use jargon that I
don't understand there's something about
a you'll be taxed at a rate of zero
mm-hmm what does that mean you're not
being taxed okay why don't you just say
you're not gonna be taxed but tax at a
rate of zero goes way over my head
I'm not that bright on this stuff but it
come on just simplify it really
simplified the problem I have with this
is the order in which this
administration tackled their issues for
example it's like you with Obamacare or
tax reform I would have loved it if they
would tax reform first they chose the
wrong lane at the supermarket they think
the Obama care lane did not move but if
you just went to the tip that the tax
the tax reform line you would have just
zoomed right through ya I hate what that
happens at the airport to know I know
you're always looking at so you always
going how did that happen that's not
there
your wife or your husband like should we
go should we move them up we do a lot of
the grocery shopping still I just tell I
just tell them I'm on the five and I'm
get right to that
that's five privilege check your
priveledge Jesse you were a little bit
disappointed a bit critical of the
president before about tax reform how
did you feel about it today because you
wanted to see some you know meaty cuts I
do I still want to see those meaty cuts
I'm not happy about a few things he's
holding out the possibility of still
raising taxes on the very wealthy mm-hmm
this is think Obama's third term you
plan to be signed up for I don't know
where he's coming off I guess this is
the populist thing or the deficit Hawk
deal I don't get it I think it's maybe
defense against I don't think a lot of
his core base want to soak the rich I
don't I think they would like tax cuts
for themselves but I don't think they're
in it to get back at the greedy
billionaires I also don't like that he's
only cutting the top rate from 39 to 35
I think it's too timid Reagan slashed
the top rate in his two terms from 72 28
to sell it as this is a Reagan s tax cut
I think is incorrect also they should be
cutting capital gains and dividend tax
cuts taxes because I think that helps
older Americans I do like some things
though I do like the income tax
reductions as a general point it's our
money it's not the government's money
the increasing of the child tax credit
and the doubling of the standard
deduction I think that helps kind of
lower middle income people and poor
Americans some of them will pay zero I
again don't understand what that means
but it sounds good
eliminates the death tax that straight
up communism that should have been out a
very long time ago and I the president
really is selling this mostly as the
corporate tax rate reduction is going to
be the key driver to growth and to job
creation and to wage growth and then
you're also going to bring back money
from overseas as well and invest more in
America it's an America
first tax cut I think there's a lot of
good things there's some bad things but
on the whole it's much better than what
we have now okay so there's room for
improvement you think but it's
definitely going in the right but I'm
probably gonna get tougher it's not
gonna if this is your opening bid it's
not going to get better that's why we
need to open the bid 15% still stewing
about it right it's still stewing okay
so one day nina said there's some things
here that the Democrats and the Liberals
should be you know okay with it
shouldn't be too displeasing to them are
you feeling pleased or displeased sort
of you know curious because I don't know
that it's you know I I think it'd be
great if we had tax reform in this
country and Blair I really do I think
people would like a more simple direct
way to know what taxes they're paying
why they're paying them and to feel that
they are going for a good use by the
government so on all those things I say
great and in fact President Trump during
the campaign promised that this would be
tax reform that it wouldn't simply be
about some tax cuts that would then open
the door to what's been described here
as tax cuts for the very rich and by the
way according to the polls NBC Wall
Street Journal's like 55 percent of
Americans oppose any kind of cut for the
corporate tax rate you know and they
also think that in fact the rich should
pay more so I don't know so but that's
that's what the American people think so
when I'm looking at this I'm thinking
also the Republicans have given up on
tax reform now all they want to do is
tax cuts and the driver is Jesse was
saying is corporate tax cuts the end and
the argument there which is an
interesting one is hey this economy
would be doing even better we'd knock
them out we would be the global Titan if
we could lower our tax rate can be
competitive with tax rates in Europe and
the rest of the world so but then when
you look at it you discover hey wait a
second our tax rates aren't out of line
guess what you know I mean you look at
the deductions and the write-offs and
our corporate tax rate in fact what
really galls me Jesse mr. populist is
that there's about half or more of
American corporations that pay zero if
you were puzzled with your Gregg this is
your answer zero means you pay no tax
right that's because all the corporate
lobbyists and swamp are sitting there in
these rooms and then
right all these things to carve out the
loopholes and the incentives that's how
it's working to me because I think the
president wants something he's given up
on tax reform he wants tax cuts but he's
opened the door to Democrats having a
very effective argument all right well
this tax reform it comes right on the
heels of another healthcare defeat as we
discussed for Republicans for the
president he's not losing hope I was
hoping this would be put on my desk
right after we won the election and I'd
come in and sign but it didn't work that
way then a couple of people that I won't
say anything but early next year when
reconciliation kicks back in in any
event long before the November election
we're going to have a vote and we're
going to be able to get that through and
I think we'll actually get it through
very easily okay
so Greg you were saying earlier that you
had to take issue yeah not with the use
of the term zero but with the order in
which the president try to it's like you
were faced with two choices a beautiful
swimming pool and a little brea tar pit
and it's like you do every time you go
to health care it's the la brea tar pit
people in california know what that is
it's like it's a big basically tar pit
yes we used to go there his kids that
was where my parents took me I was a
community pool okay here's the issue
what what was so wrong with the Graham
Cassidy bill why does this thing have to
be perfect because the thing you're
never gonna get a perfect bill and so
instead you're gonna sit here and you're
gonna one person's not gonna like this
one person so it will the perfect bill
will not exist this will not happen
mm-hmm wait a second did you just say
you don't think tax reform will happen
no I was talking about great Dana so it
was interesting because the president
mentioning this he seemed a little bit
you know upset that perhaps this was
something he wanted to do or some and we
talked about I like it that he's keeping
it open because that basically gives
them a chance to sort of look ahead and
also because he knows that a lot of
Republican donors are sitting there
thinking are you kidding me like we
don't have anything at this point so he
can blame the establishment and the
people on Capitol Hill and the
womp the truth is they he'll have to pay
the price for that but I do think that
the Democrat the Democrats still might
play ball on tax reform if the president
continues to press in these red states
that have Democratic senators that are
up for election he might be able to have
enough in order to get tax reform done
it might not be what Reagan was able to
do but that's because there's not that
much room to cut the tax rates aren't at
70% you can go from 70 to 30 when you
were in in the 80s right now it's you
just can't raise enough revenue in order
to pay for the things we want I also
think that we're having a bigger
discussion about health care and tax
reform but we're not really having it
here but the people are having it and
that is what kind of government do you
want what you expect them to be able to
pay for and how much do you think the
Americans should contribute to their
government those are bigger issue
questions yeah you know what our
children so special tax credits Oh what
does they get you get any tax credit for
having a kid I want a tax credit for my
bar bill because that's every bit as
it's as expensive as a child I think if
I if I disappeared from this earth four
or five bars to go out of business so I
could say I want a tax credit Wow
Barbie okay really relatable problems
Gregg okay Jessie what no it's a point
about kids why do you get a tax credit
that's repopulating the country why is
that come up and be doctors why should
the military why should that be part of
a tax plan oh you're gonna be able to
warded little little monsters don't grow
up to be this exactly I'm saving the
world from future Medes I didn't want to
do it I didn't want to bring this up the
time
Dayna predicted hi I'm Cassidy he's
gonna pass I had hope and faith but the
president left the door open so if this
clip I'm going again
it's a look you're gonna say in wine was
right all along
no never not gonna go that far
hysterically hey listen
she's a glass you know half full come on
people come up